IT WILL BE LATE JUNE AT BEST.
>> Bret: CATHERINE, THINK YOU
PRAY OF THE TERM ADMINISTRATION
WAS GIVEN AN ADVANCE WARNING OF
MUELLER'S STATEMENT TODAY.
AFTER WATCHING THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL, THEY HAD A COORDINATED
RESPONSE.
IT IS TIME TO MOVE ON.
CORRESPONDENT KEVIN CORKE HAS A
REACTION THE WHITE HOUSE.
>> FROM THE PIPES PRESIDENT OF
THE WHITE HOUSE PRESS SECRETARY,
TO THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN TO THE
PRIVATE ATTORNEYS.
A MUTUAL BLIZZARD OF STATEMENTS
FROM INSIDE AND OUTSIDE THE
TRUMP WHITE HOUSE ABOUT BOB
MUELLER'S COMMENTS TODAY, EACH
WITH A DEFINITIVE CONCLUSION,
JAY SEKULOW SAID IT PUTS A
PERIOD ON A 2-YEAR
INVESTIGATION, THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN WROTE THAT THERE WAS NO
CASE OF OBSTRUCTION, EVEN
VICE PRESIDENT MIKE PENCE
WEIGHED IN.
THE INVESTIGATION IS COMPLETE.
ALL FOR CLAIMING AN END TO THE
INVESTIGATION THAT THE
WHITE HOUSE OFFICIALS BELIEVE
SHOULD HAVE NEVER TAKEN PLACE TO
BEGIN WITH.
>> HE SAID THAT IT WAS
COMPLETED.
HE IS CASE CLOSED, AND SHUTTING
DOWN HIS OFFICE.
AND GOING BACK TO HIS PRIVATE
LIFE.
WE THINK THAT IT IS GREAT THAT
HE IS DOING THAT AND WE HOPE
THAT EVERYBODY ELSE DOES THAT AS
WELL.
>> THE SENTIMENT ECHOED BY THE
PRESIDENT WHO TOOK TO TWITTER TO
CLAIM HIS INNOCENCE.
THERE WAS INSUFFICIENT EVIDENCE
AND IN OUR COUNTRY, A PERSON IS
INNOCENT.
THE CASE IS CLOSED.
CASE CLOSED FROM THE PRESIDENT'S
PERSPECTIVE, BUT NOT TO MUELLER
WHOSE COMMENTS TODAY LEAD THE
WHITE HOUSE TO WONDER IF HE WAS
NEARLY SETTING THE STAGE FOR
CONGRESSIONAL DEMOCRATS TO
CONTINUE A IMPEACHMENT DRUMBEAT.
RUDY GIULIANI, A FREQUENT CRITIC
OF THE TEAM WAS BEMUSED.
>> WHEN A PROSECUTOR CANNOT
REACH A DECISION, THAT IS A
DECISION.
THERE IS NO CASE ON OBSTRUCTION,
AND I NEVER EXONERATE EVERYONE.
IS THERE ENOUGH EVIDENCE TO
BRING A CHARGE OR ISN'T THERE
ENOUGH CHARGE?
END OF CASE.
>> BARRING A CONGRESSIONAL
SUBPOENA, MAKING HIS CONTINUING
LOOKING AT NOT TESTIFYING
FURTHER.
THE WORDS ARE THE FINAL REPORT
ON THE TOPIC.